Ang terminong quantum teleportation ay maaaring mukhang bagay na mula sa science fiction ngunit gaya ng tatalakayin natin sa episode ngayon
ng Qiskit in the Classroom ito ay isang tunay at lubhang kapaki-pakinabang na pamamaraan para sa quantum communication at
networking Maligayang pagdating sa Qiskit in the classroom Sa seryeng ito gagamitin natin ang Qiskit upang tuklasin ang ilang pundamental
na konsepto na karaniwang tinatalakay sa mga kursong may kaugnayan sa quantum computing Ang bawat video ay sinasamahan ng isang interactive na module
na naka-link sa paglalarawan sa ibaba kaya siguruhing tingnan ito Ang teleportation ay isang uri ng science fiction at fantasy
na tropiko sa ngayon Ang isang tao o bagay ay nawawala mula sa isang lokasyon at agad na lumalabas sa ibang lugar
Kahit gaano kaganda nito sa kasamaang palad ang ganitong uri ng teleportation ay imposible Lalabag ito sa cosmic
na speed limit Walang maaaring maglakbay nang mas mabilis kaysa sa liwanag Ngunit ang quantum teleportation ay
posible Sa quantum teleportation ang impormasyon sa halip na bagay ay maaaring maipadala sa pagitan ng dalawang
malalayong lokasyon Kailangan mo lamang ng isang pares ng mga entangled na particle isa sa bawat lokasyon at isang paraan upang ipagpalit ang classical
na impormasyon sa pagitan ng dalawang lokasyon Ang protocol na ito ay binuo noong 1993 ng isang pangkat
ng mga quantum scientist kabilang ang Charles Bennett ng IBM Tinawag nila itong quantum teleportation dahil katulad ng
bersyon ng science fiction ang quantum na impormasyon ay nawala mula sa isang lokasyon at lumabas sa isa pang malalayong
lokasyon nang hindi dumaan sa pagitan ng espasyo Maaaring mukhang mahiwagang bagay ito ngunit gaya ng makikita natin walang
misteryoso o mahiwagang tungkol dito Ito ay pinahintulutan ng penomenon ng quantum entanglement kasabay ng classical
na komunikasyon Ngayon lalakad tayo sa quantum teleportation protocol at kung paano ito gumagana At pagkatapos ilalagay natin ito sa
aksyon sa isang tunay na quantum computer upang i-teleport ang state ng isang qubit mula sa isang bahagi ng isang IBM quantum processor patungo sa
isa pa Kaya narito kung paano gumagana ang quantum teleportation Ipagpalagay na mayroon tayong dalawang tao sina Alice at Bob na pinaghiwalay
ng malaking distansya Sabihin nating mayroon si Alice ng isang qubit Tatawagin nating qubit Q para sa kaginhawahan At nasa
ilang hindi kilalang quantum state sq kung saan ang alpha 0 at alpha 1 ay mga kumplikadong
numero Nais ni Alice na ipadala ang kanyang state kay Bob ngunit wala siyang paraan upang tunay na maipadala ang qubit mismo Maaaring
masyadong malayo siya o marahil hindi niya alam kung nasaan eksaktong si Bob kaya hindi niya alam kung saan ipadala ito Sa kabutihang palad
ang mga kaibigan ay nagtataglay na ng isang pares ng entangled na qubit na A at B kung saan mayroon si Alice ng qubit A at si Bob ay may qubit B At
ang mga qubit na ito ay entangled Sa pamamagitan ng entangled ibig ko sabihin kahit na ang dalawang qubit ay pinaghiwalay ng malaking
distansya ang kanilang mga state ay may ugnayan sa isang paraan na hindi kayang ipaliwanag ng classical na physics Ang entangled na pares na ito ay
tinatawag na ebit na maaari nating gamitin bilang isang resource sa quantum computing at komunikasyon
Sa kasong ito maaaring gamitin ni Alice ang ebit bilang isang resource upang maiparating ang kanyang quantum na impormasyon kay Bob Upang makita kung paano
simulan nating isulat ang joint state ng lahat ng tatlong qubit na ito kung saan inayos ko ang mga qubit nang medyo arbitraryo
sa puntong ito ngunit ang pagkakasunod-sunod na ito ay magiging maginhawa kapag pinatakbo natin ang ating eksperimento sa Qiskit Sa Qiskit ang karaniwang paraan ng
pag-order ng mga qubit ay kanan pakaliwa Kaya ang state ng qubit zero ay lilitaw sa kanan
I-expand natin nang kaunti ang state at isulat itong muli tulad nito Pagkatapos ang unang hakbang sa ating teleportation protocol ay
para kay Alice na i-entangle ang kanyang data qubit kasama ang kanyang kalahati ng ebit qubit gamit ang isang C-not gate Ang isang C-not o controlled-not
gate ay magbabago ng state ng isang qubit ang target qubit depende sa state ng isa pang qubit ang control qubit
Kung ang control qubit ay nasa state zero wala itong nangyayari sa target At kung ang control qubit ay nasa
state isa ang target qubit ay nababaligtad Kaya sa kasong ito ang data qubit Q ni Alice ang magiging control qubit at
ang kanyang ebit qubit A ang magiging target qubit Kaya ang unang dalawang term ay hindi nagbago sa pamamagitan ng C-not ngunit ang
huling dalawang term ay nagbago dahil ang control qubit Q ay nasa state isa Pagkatapos ay mag-apply
si Alice ng Hadamard gate sa kanyang data qubit Q na nagdadala ng state 0 sa state 1/2 0 + 1 at ang state 1 sa
1 over 2 0 -1 Lalaktawan ko ang ilang simpleng algebra dito na maaari mong subukang punan nang mag-isa kung gusto mo
Ngunit pagkatapos ng muling pag-aayos ng ilang term makakakuha ka ng isang state na ganito Kaya ngayon ang tatlong qubit na
entangled na state ni Alice at Bob ay nagmumukhang ganap na kalat Ngunit tingnan kung ano ang mangyayari kung susukat ni Alice ang parehong qubit niya Ang tatlong
qubit na state ay bahagyang magco-collapse sa isa sa apat na ito
na term At sa bawat kaso ang qubit ni Bob ay maiiwan na may superposition state na may amplitudes na may kaugnayan sa
paunang hindi kilalang state ni Alice Tandaan ang mga amplitude ay alpha 0 at alpha 1 Kaya
halimbawa kung susukat ni Alice ang parehong qubit bilang zero ang state ni Bob ay magco-collapse sa term na ito ang orihinal
na hindi kilalang state na nais i-teleport ni Alice Ngunit kung ang sukat ni Alice ay zero sa qubit A at isa sa qubit Q ang state ni Bob
ay ito Ang state na ito ay maaaring baguhin sa orihinal na state ng qubit Q kung mag-apply si Bob ng
isang Z gate na magbabaligtad ng sign na ito dito Ngunit hindi malalaman ni Bob na gawin ito
hanggang sa malaman niya kung ano ang nasukat ni Alice Kaya ang susunod na hakbang sa protocol ay para kay Alice na tawagan si Bob at sabihin sa kanya kung ano
ang kanyang dalawang sukat Pagkatapos malaman niya iyon malalaman na niya kung anong mga operasyon ang isasagawa sa kanyang qubit upang tumugma ito sa
orihinal na state ni Alice Narito ang isang talahanayan ng apat na posibleng sukat at apat na posibleng operasyon na kailangang
gawin ni Bob sa kanyang qubit batay sa mga sukat na iyon Maaaring kailanganin ni Bob na mag-apply ng isang Z gate isang X gate o pareho upang
i-transform ang kanyang qubit upang tumugma sa orihinal na qubit ni Alice Ang huling hakbang na ito kung saan tinatawagan ni Alice si Bob sa pamamagitan ng daan ay kung bakit
ang quantum teleportation ay hindi lumalabag sa causality Kahit na agad na nagco-collapse ang state ni Bob nang sumukat si Alice ng
kanyang mga qubit hindi makukuha ni Bob ang anumang impormasyon mula sa state na iyon hanggang sabihin ni Alice kay Bob kung ano ang kanyang nasukat At
ang tawag na iyon ay limitado ng bilis ng liwanag Dumaan na tayo sa maraming detalyadong matematika kaya ang kamangha-manghang katotohanang
na-teleport na natin ang quantum na impormasyon ay maaaring nawala Ngunit tunay itong kahanga-hanga Sa pamamagitan ng paggamit ng
entanglement bilang isang resource maaaring gumawa si Alice ng isang sukat upang sirain ang quantum na impormasyong nakaimbak sa kanya at ipakita ito
sa isa pang malalayong lokasyon na kay Bob Ang distansyang ito ay maaaring daan-daan kahit libu-libong kilometro Higit pa riyan
kamangha-mangha ang protocol na ito ay hindi nangangailangan na eksaktong malaman ni Alice kung nasaan si Bob Hangga't nagtataglay sila ng isang ebit
at maaari silang mag-communicate nang classical ang quantum teleportation ay gagana Ngayon tingnan natin kung paano ito gumagana
gamit ang Qiskit at tunay na i-teleport ang isang quantum state sa isang quantum computer
Magsisimula tayo sa tatlong qubit isa para sa data qubit Q at ang mga qubit A at B na bumubuo sa ebit Magsisimula tayo sa pamamagitan ng
paglikha ng ebit Mag-apply tayo ng Hadamard sa qubit A na sinusundan ng isang C-not
sa pagitan ng A at B upang lumikha ng entangled state na hinahanap natin
Pagkatapos ihahanda natin ang qubit Q ni Alice sa isang random na quantum state sa pamamagitan ng pag-apply ng isang random unitary na ipinapakita ng kahon na may label
U Pagkatapos ay darating na ang teleportation Una ang C-not sa pagitan ng mga qubit Q at A Pagkatapos ang Hadamard sa
qubit Q Pagkatapos ang mga sukat ay bahagyang magco-collapse ang state upang ang qubit B lamang ni Bob ay nasa superposition
Ito ang puntong tatawagin ni Alice si Bob at sasabihin sa kanya kung ano ang kanyang nasukat Pagkatapos mag-apply si Bob ng ilang
gate depende sa mga sukat na iyon Ang mga pulang nakabalangkas na kahon na ito ay nagpapakita ng mga conditional na gate Ang una ay nangangahulugan
na mag-apply si Bob ng isang X gate sa kanyang qubit kung ang qubit A ay nasukat bilang isa At
ang pangalawa ay nangangahulugan na mag-apply din siya ng isang Z gate kung ang qubit Q ay nasukat bilang isa
Kaya ngayon dapat mayroon si Bob ng isang qubit sa parehong state na nasa qubit ni Alice sa puntong ito dito pagkatapos ng unitary gate
Kung lahat ay naayon sa plano na-teleport na natin ang quantum state Ngunit paano natin ito masusuri Maaari nating patakbuhin ang
parehong circuit ngunit gumawa ng isang maliit na pagbabago
Dito idinagdag natin ang isa pang unitary sa dulo ng circuit na inilapat sa qubit ni Bob Ang unitary na ito ay ang inverse ng
isa na inilapat natin sa simula sa qubit ni Alice Ang dahilan dito ay kung ang unang gate na ito ay lumikha ng
quantum state na ngayon ay na-teleport na sa qubit ni Bob ang isa na ito ay dapat na i-undo ito na nagdadala ng qubit ni Bob pabalik sa zero
state Ngunit siyempre nino-undo nito ang lahat ng ating pagsisikap sa pag-teleport ng state sa unang lugar Kaya hindi natin ito gusto
gawin kung tunay nating nais gawin ang isang bagay sa na-teleport na state at kung tunay itong nasa isang hindi kilalang quantum
state hindi tayo makakaapply ng unitary upang i-undo ito Kahit papaano ito ay para lamang sa diagnostic na layunin upang
matiyak na matagumpay ang teleportation Kung susukat natin na nasa zero state ang qubit ni Bob maaari tayong maging medyo
sigurado na naging matagumpay ang teleportation Kapag natiyak na ang ating protocol ay gumagana gaya ng inaasahan maaari nating alisin ang
panghuling unitary na ito at tunay na gumawa ng isang bagay gamit ang na-teleport na state Ngunit sa ngayon tiyakin lamang nating gumagana ito
I-execute natin ang circuit sa isang quantum computer Maaari nating gamitin ang Qiskit primitive sampler upang patakbuhin ang circuit na ito
nang maraming beses at mangolekta ng mga istatistika sa mga kinalabasan ng sukat Kung perpektong na-teleport natin ang state ni Alice kay Bob sa bawat
pagkakataon susukat ni Bob ng zero ang kanyang qubit sa bawat pagkakataon ngunit sa kapaligiran na may ingay at mga kapintasan sa
mga gate maaari nating asahan na makakita ng ilang run kung saan ang qubit ni Bob ay nagiging isa Ngunit hangga't karamihan ng
oras ang qubit ni Bob ay nasukat bilang zero maaari nating tawaging tagumpay ito Narito mayroon tayong isang histogram ng mga kinalabasan ng sukat ng
lahat ng tatlong qubit Ang sukat ni Bob ay ipinapakita bilang unang slot ng bawat tatlong bit na string Gaya ng inaasahan ang apat
na kinalabasan na katumbas ng kanyang bit na zero ay mas malamang kaysa sa iba pang apat Kaya matagumpay nating
na-teleport ang isang quantum state Ngunit tingnan kung gaano kalayo ang ating na-teleport Ito ay isang mapa ng lahat ng
qubit sa quantum processor na ginamit natin At sa eksperimento gumamit lamang tayo ng tatlong qubit na ito
Ang qubit ni Alice ay nandito at ang qubit ni Bob ay nandito Kaya halos katabi sila Maaari sana nating
makamit ang pareho sa pamamagitan lamang ng pag-apply ng ilang swap gate na gaya ng iminumungkahi ng pangalan ay nagpapalit ng mga quantum state
ng dalawang katabing qubit Ang quantum teleportation ay kapaki-pakinabang para sa pagdadala ng quantum na impormasyon sa malalayong distansya at
ang mga quantum state ay na-teleport na ng daan-daang kilometro noon Para sa ating mga eksperimento dito limitado tayo ng
laki ng chip ngunit maaari nating gawing mas kahanga-hanga ang teleportation sa pamamagitan ng pag-teleport ng isang state sa pagitan ng dalawang
malalayong qubit sa ating quantum computer Kaya subukan natin iyon Narito ang ating bagong circuit diagram Ito ay medyo mas
kumplikado ngunit walang napakahalaga na nagbago maliban na ngayon sina Alice at Bob ay lumilikha ng kanilang shared ebit
at pagkatapos ay naghiwalay Ang serye ng mga linya at X na ito ay kumakatawan sa mga swap gate na inililipat
ang mga state ni Alice at Bob mula sa isang qubit patungo sa isa pa Lumilipat si Alice pataas sa qubit 1 at
si Bob ay bumababa sa qubit 12 Pagkatapos lumilikha si Alice ng kanyang random na state sa qubit 0 gamit ang
unitary na ito Tandaan na gumagawa siya ng state pagkatapos niyang at ni Bob na naghiwalay na
Kaya malayo na si Bob sa kanya
Pagkatapos ang teleportation protocol ay nagpapatuloy gaya ng dati at natapos si Bob na may orihinal na state ni Alice pagkatapos ng kanyang
mga conditional na operasyon Inilalapat natin ang inverse unitary gate at pagkatapos ay bebe-beripikahan na ang qubit ni Bob ay
nasa state zero At muli ay nakikita natin na karamihan ng oras ang qubit ni Bob ay nasumpungang nasa zero
state Kaya matagumpay ang teleportation
Ang rate ng tagumpay ay hindi masyadong mataas gaya ng nang magkatabi sina Alice at Bob Ang lahat ng swap gate na iyon
ay maaaring mahal at nagdudulot ng kaunting pagkasira ng ebit Ang quantum teleportation ay maaaring mukhang mahiwagang bagay ngunit gaya ng ating nakita
kailangan lamang nito ng entanglement isang classical na channel ng komunikasyon at ilang talino Ang orihinal na 1993
na panukala na tinakpan natin sa video na ito ay naglatag ng pundasyon para sa iba pang mga protocol tulad ng quantum gate
teleportation at isang mahalagang sangkap para sa quantum computation at komunikasyon
Sa eksperimental na larangan patuloy na itinulak ng mga siyentipiko ang mga hangganan ng quantum teleportation kahit na nagawa nilang i-teleport
ang quantum state ng isang photon sa pagitan ng isang laboratoryo sa Lupa at isang satellite na 1,400 km
sa itaas nito At i-teleport ang mga quantum state sa pamamagitan ng isang maingay na classical na internet cable Kung gusto mong i-teleport ang iyong sariling
quantum state pumunta sa quantum teleportation module na naka-link sa paglalarawan sa ibaba Salamat sa panonood
at hanggang sa muli